July 2017 saw the release and immediate
embrace of spider-man's MCU reboot which
featured Tom Holland as New York's
friendly neighborhood wall-crawler in
2018 we got to see another dimension to
the franchise literally in the animated
masterpiece spider-man into the
spider-verse are you okay
not what's going on with your body I
don't think my atoms are real jazzed
about being in the wrong dimension the
film introduced multiple Spidey
characters including Brooklyn teen Miles
Morales and Gwen Stacy the Spider Woman
of her universe who was known to fans as
spider-gwen quick-witted confident and
able to pull off an impromptu haircut
Stacy's battle skills and warm heart
meter an instant fan favorite into the
spider-verse wasn't Stacy's first
appearance on the big screen but it was
the first time we saw the character with
powers she was played by Bryce Dallas
Howard in 2007 spider-man 3 the last
movie in the Tobey Maguire starring
trilogy she had a bigger role in the
Andrew Garfield franchise in which she
was played by Emma Stone
but these versions of guang are based on
the canonical spider-man in which
spoiler alert she dies tragically
spider-gwen however first appeared in
the comics in 2014 and got her own
series in 2015 she lives in an alternate
universe where she was bitten by the
radioactive spider instead of her best
friend Parker and she later fails to
save him giving her a similar guilt
tinged motivation to her mainstream
counterparts powers check sad origin
story check sense of humor in hearts
check but will spider-gwen ever get her
own movie see you around spider-man
[Music]
while there are no firm plans to give
spider-gwen her own live-action solo
film at this moment it's safe to say
that there's never been a better time at
the cinema for female superheroes after
years of being left out or relegated to
the background these characters are
finally seeing their names and lights in
2017 DC's Wonder Woman became the
highest-grossing superhero origin story
ever it was surpassed in 2019 by Captain
Marvel the MC use first film centered on
a female superhero we know there will be
a Captain Marvel to coming along within
the next few years and we're also
getting movies focused on Black Widow
and a female Thor played by Natalie
Portman in the MCU phase four on the
small screen
Disney Plus will be offering up the
Wanda vision series which focuses on
Scarlet Witch and two more about MS
Marvel and she-hulk more immediately we
can get our damsels in no distress fix
at the cinema via DC's anti-heroin
Harley Quinn in birds-of-prey the
creators of into the spider verse drew
on the ideas of Marvel mastermind Stan
Lee who always liked spider-man because
he could be anyone under the mask they
were able to get audiences pumped about
Spidey's who weren't necessarily white
male or well human and with their
newfound emphasis on showcasing female
heroes it feels like the right time for
Stacy to take center stage we aren't the
only ones who want to see more
spider-gwen rumors have abounded that
Marvel parent company Disney is very
keen on the character and that Marvel
wants her to have her own solo MCU movie
which might also connect to a potential
film based on The Young Avengers and you
know what we might already have seen her
eagle-eyed fans watching Avengers end
game at home spotted a student at Peter
Parker's high school with blonde hair a
pink backpack and a skirt with a
spiderweb design the MCU has already
sneaked in a reference to spider-verse
hero Miles Morales and spider-man
homecoming when Aaron Davis played by
Donald Glover mentions that he has an
unnamed nephew who was confirmed to be
Myles in a deleted scene yes I'm I'm
gonna make it yeah I'm just stuck
whether we get to see a live action
version of Stacey on screen or not it's
all but certain that she'll be back in
animated form into the spider-verse did
quite well at the box office and even
beat out Incredibles 2 for the Best
Animated Feature Oscar this promptly led
to the green lighting of a sequel which
will further explore Myles and Gwen's
relationship and we're also getting an
animated spin-off led by Stacy that film
will feature an all-female team of
superheroes including Jessica drew the
main continuity Spider Woman and Cindy
moon aka silk all of this bodes well for
Stacy's live-action fortunes and while
we don't know exactly when or how it
will happen we're pretty sure she won't
be leaving all of the web slinging to
the boys for much longer
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]